[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
what we talk about whatever we want
do you let me buzz in the mail saying
like don't worry girl I got the hats I'm
late I actually have a whole pack of
them but I didn't wanna have to hand
them out to all you guys what I have so
you just gotta like fold it okay so I've
been doing JK knees with you guys for
one year
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry too much we gotta-we others
like start ignoring her likes much now
the one time that instrument is
appropriate didn't only don't say it's
appropriate yeah so I literally ordered
these two weeks ago and four weeks ago I
got him okay so that's it yeah talking
about this forever and I don't even get
a [ __ ] and do not have it but you
wanted them dang I won't have to see her
and hold up you a half never mind that
thank you Joe
thank you thank you guys for dealing
with me for a whole year I like how you
bought your own party things that's
that's what she knew that she knew we
were gonna do [ __ ] I see Christopher
Robin movie no is it good i watch that
[ __ ] the other way Robin movie oh I
started watching you at angle by Anthony
Tucker it's an adult movie all right
damn it
I don't know wait Christopher Robin like
the Winnie the Pooh it is actually made
for adults okay what's his name that
movie is very reminiscent to remind of
adults about having fun and like cues
like when I watch that book so out of
all the Disney characters out there
woody the Pooh is my favorite cause he's
got no pants like I'm is exercise yeah
yeah yeah shows like first of all the CG
animation is amazing but there was a
line in that film that [ __ ] got me
dude this fool says cuz you don't even
know but Winnie the Pooh has [ __ ] jam
of lines I'm talking about life lessons
this will say oh he's a rapper
everybody says nothing's impossible but
I do it all the time
like a rapper get it nothing's
impossible but he doesn't do anything at
all all the time
I [ __ ] love it dude but if I when I
watched actually cried it made me cry
damn I didn't like what did the poop
growing up cuz I felt like he was him
and his crew were so negative especially
like Eeyore so when I would watch I was
complaining I was like bro that's why
you fed
yeah you didn't know winnie-the-pooh
they look Christopher Robin dude it's
like yeah maybe not maybe I should give
him another time they have so many like
I think for me when I have a kid he's
gonna watch Winnie the Pooh all the time
because we need the Pooh is such a
[ __ ] positive character yeah oh he
was okay I gotta give him another try
the only ers we need the Pooh quotes
right now and it's gonna make you feel
good dude I didn't like the art book you
know the whole movie that they made I
had the book but it was like legit like
the read find everything woody the Pooh
aren't coming right now
just for my [ __ ] apartment right now
that's the time man and it made you cry
it made me cry because like it's just
because in that film Christopher Robin
is denying everything that he wants in
life because he's saying that he has to
be an adult and so it kind of reminds me
about what a lot of adults go through so
you you are told that you have to be
this way if you are an adult you have to
do this you have to do that you have to
let go of this childhood want and needs
in order for you to be a good person
yeah but Christopher Robin when after he
separates from Winnie the Pooh for so
many years
he comes back and then Winnie the Pooh
comes back to him and when he book he's
reminding him like oh I'm your childhood
like you you you you're not happy like
why are you not happy and I just like
made me come was about to make funny you
but I'm about to cry too you know my dad
told me almost made me cry the other
house on the phone with them so he was
telling me and it's kind of like along
the same lines he told me the reason why
he loves hanging out with Tiger so much
is because when he's with him he has
such an angel like an innocent presence
that he gets teleported back to when he
was his age oh so it's like nothing
matters mortgages don't matter taxes
don't matter maybe that explains Michael
Jackson's whole thing too that whoa whoa
Karl
exactly how he feels yeah I think it's a
little bit different but my dad but with
my dad's with tight guys it feels like
he's also a little kid he just got
transported back and it's like during
this own little bubble and the other
thing that he said that I was all [ __ ]
hop is so like uh unemotional yeah I
spent a lot of time with like watching
their interaction and I would never
guess that cuz your dad just giggles and
he just sits there but that is still I
guess it is in his hands I got he slam
dunking on a [ __ ] moon the other
thing that my dad also said was he was
like I'm never ever ever gonna
discipline him he's like that's your job
because y'all never ever discipline
because he was like when you get older
and you realize that you only have a
short amount of time with the kid
because he's like you're gonna have a
whole lifetime with this kid he goes for
me I might have 18 years I might have 20
years if I'm lucky and he was like when
you only have that short amount of time
you don't have enough time to spend it
on sad times you know what I'm like he's
gonna be like damn [ __ ] why'd you beat
me
similar mm to say oh he learned from you
yeah I never saw I never thought like
funny it's because my uncle said the
same thing to his kids and all of us cuz
he was like really proud of me he was he
was giving him praise like oh man you
really like went against the grain and
you you you you you know we told you to
do one thing but you went the other way
and you really built something for
yourself and then I think that's the key
to happiness is to just like do what you
believe is right and in all of his kids
they're like in their 40s right they're
like it would have been nice if you told
us earlier black man and he's like yeah
I [ __ ] dogs he's like 80 right yeah so
he's like recognizing that now yeah but
it's like damn it probably is worse for
him yeah cuz he's 80 no he can't turn
that back but he's realizing it now this
is the one that only ate pasta and
butter thought it was healthy
a lot of things wrong
he became diabetic he had a lot of rice
and he ate a lot of instant noodles and
he didn't eat meat because you know he
thought that was unhealthy
so in because but you'd be hungry
because he's always eating just carbs so
he got diabetic yes interesting man yeah
see all that stuff that you said right
there that's the [ __ ] Christopher
Robin movie man and so as an adult I
think when you're younger you watch is
gonna be like oh this is really childish
but if you watch it as an adult it makes
you kind of reflect on your life and
yeah and you kind of look at yourself as
Christopher Robin as an adult so he was
like you see his relationship with his
daughter his daughter is about to go to
boarding school and she just wants to
spend time with her dad he doesn't know
I have to work so I have to work I have
to work it hold the buddy and then his
daughter super yeah good and when we
need the Pooh comes back in his life you
kind of just see like him just just
start to unravel how unhappy is he happy
if we were living in grass huts in a
tribe we see each other every day take
care of each other baby's gonna have to
worry about that [ __ ] but we chose to be
civilized what the sad part is too like
in the film Christopher Robin just this
is live action this is a CG animated
thing so like who is an actual being you
want you and McGregor yes like my thing
is like when I hear live-action I think
winning the Pooh I'm like is it animated
because of his live-action I feel like
Winnie the Pooh would look creepy no
it's kind of like Ted yeah yeah yeah we
need a PUD Christopher Walken I would
watch that and it's you at you Ewan Ewan
McGregor is so [ __ ] for Walken ooh
what are you doing here like what the
[ __ ] is with this guy speech pattern are
you telling me you'll bet tip will makes
you cry she's a waterfall from her
eyeball okay what makes you cry or not
what makes me cry uh onions
no put on the spot I can't think of
anything I don't know things okay you
answer I don't know I feel almost every
sad article makes you cry I used to be
old to okay cut the head more of a
tender heart now I'm a little bit of
scar you know I'm scarred guard - mine
is have y'all ever seen Michelle what
would you do before no yeah it's where
they put people in like situations I see
how fake as [ __ ] hello that show your
crowd of that yeah because I saw I
started I would like okay I do this
thing we're like I'm super emotional and
I've learned to control my emotions I
have to force myself to cry occasionally
I'm not kidding my boyfriend's like what
the [ __ ] the force yourself tired no
it's pretty easy I just turned on what
would you do but people being nice
people makes me cry
that makes me cry it's so what without
it fail really talented people make oh I
see that's what I mean like it's so
beautiful
[Laughter]
that makes me cry like a dude with like
his balls on like a wooden plank and he
just has a brick he's like I think
Bart's just you know that guy that
[ __ ] attaches the napkin to a fan and
it kind of makes you cry singing singing
I like really good evening painting like
I don't know do you ever cry on
America's Got Talent videos where like
you expect them not to be a good singer
yeah baby yeah yeah yeah I get that too
every time okay
it's like those videos especially those
commercials I really tell you your
heartstrings from like a kid growing up
and then the parent can't grow up like
did you ever see this short film your
bear no short if this little bow right
little dumpling this woman she makes a
little dumpling and then it turns it
alive you know that makes you cry what
would you do
yeah you can't see thank you you know
that show makes me mad first start
watching it I was like oh this might be
fake and then I like move to LA and I
was like oh this is probably fake and
then I googled what would you do fake
and the first thing that came up was a
reddit post and it was like I was a
person that got caught up in what would
you do and they said the whole thing was
real and I was like that's I was like
Joe just have this whoa okay living some
of these episodes I just stopped you
can't let you have it why why Joe okay
all right let me I'm not I'm gonna let
you have this but this is the reason why
I get mad at it okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna destroy your dream what what
it is is weird
no no so so that's the reaction you get
is
people are so nice right that's what you
get right what I see is oh I was in that
situation I [ __ ] all of them up like I
started getting fired up like I would
have thought would have told them off
like I would have gone there if I can
told them up yeah that's a good ok no no
no cuz this show is like so for example
when one of it is like oh there's a
asian guy in a white girl and then she
has to tell her parents like you seal
off you saw that way she has to tell
their parents and her parents are
rejecting right and then like people are
overhearing the conversation and then
they'll they'll go up and don't like
give the girl support or the couples
support they're like you know what I
think if you're in love you should do
what you want and don't worry about what
your parents say and then they walk away
you know and it's so like they cause a
scene on purpose it's like social
experiment yeah see what people
bystanders would do and a lot of
regional Lucy TVs yeah but then I'm like
I'm so extreme if I was in there I would
probably do one completely ignore and
laugh at them or to be all up in their
faces and like have a crazy
confrontation and an ethical cut cut cut
they're like we gotta get them he's
about to go off can I get all mad
afterwards because I'm like that's so
[ __ ] up man yo y'all never want to
catch me on that show John quinones
comes out it's like hey you're on what
would you do I just I like seeing things
of people being good people
yeah I feel like the people's reaction
isn't fake like the bystanders I feel
like that's real okay yeah but no the
acting's fake because we know it's me
you know what else is weird what's like
really suspicious about it like I
noticed this in the show I know they're
miked up but they're talking
significantly louder than they need to
be because they try to attract attention
and it's just like it's like so
over-the-top well is that the show where
they give a person a random like Magga
hat to wear just to see how the people
react basically yeah I think they know
it's a TV show a TV show right the
Korean version of that too where Meryl
was crying because there's this guy that
he didn't know how to tie his tie and so
there was a bunch of old Korean leaders
to keep my god that's so innocent and
they're like oh let me help you tie your
tie and the guy didn't have any gloves
so this little lady she has she had a
heat pack on her stomach she goes their
hands are cold you can't go into your
interview like that so she took her out
and she started warming his hand with it
that his tie from the metal
she was like giving you advice tonight
okay you're gonna get the job laughs my
comedic ass would like I would always be
like trying to one-up it cuz I'm like
this is so basic right like you're gonna
have like a mixed couple and then a
white parents not allowing that I'm like
why couldn't it be like Asian parents
being hella races and saying [ __ ] like
and see what happens or or like someone
takes a [ __ ] in the bathroom they don't
have any toilet paper and they yell
excuse me paper and see who helps them
like [ __ ] like that that's what I want
to see actually would be hilarious right
like someone [ __ ] their pants in public
and see what happens like who's gonna
help them who's gonna help this crazy
process annoyed suit pants yeah who
would switch pants with this person yeah
I got a job interview I just [ __ ] my
pants will you switch pants with me you
know did you guys ever see that one show
that we talked about I hear it where
they pretty much pushed this person to
commit murder yeah oh yeah that push or
something yeah like it was so bad off
because the Builder was too long yeah it
was like 12 steps
but they lost me when they had the they
had it they took his phone in the
beginning and I was like yeah but that
show would have ended real quick with us
though so you had to kill him on the
show yeah they would have just been like
okay well the [ __ ] season ended in
one episode in 10 minutes could this guy
you knew he wanted to say some [ __ ] and
was like okay but he's so beta that like
he just let everyone do whatever he
wanted I would have just been like yo
why did we do that or why like you just
ask questions we'll be like you had to
kill him you're not gonna tell anybody I
yeah they're waiting for the [ __ ] y'all
want to cry I'm not I I posted about
this but okay so yesterday well yeah
today is over there yesterday I needed a
new pair of I like headphones for my
phone like iPhone headphones and you
know how you have to plug them in or
have the adapter right so I went to
Walgreens to get some new ones and I get
there and of course they don't have the
iPhone ones and they but they have
Wireless and I'm like oh I probably need
to upgrade anyway I thought it was slick
because I got this like $20 like ripoff
ear pods that's how you looking over
there tell me why this [ __ ] cost me $20
I thing is huge
what is this cord so that's for you to
speak into no but I mean like the
picture was air pods
oh my god it's what I got and I thought
I was getting one up cuz I was like oh
$20 the technologies yes would you give
we're trying to get $20 [ __ ] air box
I look like a gym teacher
and I can't put it behind me because
this is the microphone you're like a
retainer broke or something
like cry but I'm not it doesn't work if
there's that control the volume and
everything I don't know it doesn't work
they don't work at all you got you know
you have it then $20 I mean I thought I
was being slick like I really did like I
thought that I was getting a deal I was
like people paying 399 for air pause you
know with the air plus because you guys
have long hair so when it's in there
people can't really see it so you know
with guys just looks like two little
[ __ ] dildos out their ears and just
[ __ ] walking around you know but you
guys we just covered it so it's nice
okay yeah everyone has them and I
thought that a [ __ ] ooh it's oh [ __ ] I
bet you it's designed by a guy yeah you
see that yeah and a bomber jacket no no
no
lots of socks cuz no I'm David I'm sorry
but that's how you met your ladies so
it's like sentimental well I did it but
we look like a ninja I'm only allowed to
wear this [ __ ] when she's not around and
what's funny is his socks don't even fit
in there like falling off his [ __ ]
foot how do you watch rocks and sandals
I got nice Bowl like a wedgie in your
foot oh it feels good like a front
wedgie because without the socks it's a
little cold but what the soft is just
right get slides no they don't hold as
firm as he split Oh like Birkenstocks
maybe something that doesn't have that I
look like a biblical character you I'm
not wearing those dang
all right Moses you're good then
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]